[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo le magazine des temps forts de la
semaine à l'assemblée et au sénat avec
orianne monsigny bonjour oriane
gentiment est notre invité cette semaine
et sophie primas sénatrice les
républicains des yvelines et président
de la commission des affaires
économiques du sénat bonjour à vous
bonjour à vous donne et une semaine bien
sûr marqué par la crise des gilet jaune
à la provoquer la modification de
l'ordre du jour du parlement
edouard philippe est venu défendre sa
politique et ses mesures devant les deux
assemblées
christophe castaner lui a dû s'expliquer
devant les commissions des lois sur sa
gestion des manifestations
deux sujets ont particulièrement fait
débat cette semaine la taxe sur les
carburants emmanuel macron a finalement
suivi le vote du sénat
en supprimant la route prévue le 1er
janvier autre débat la suppression de
l'impôt sur la fortune pas question pour
emmanuel macron de le rétablir
mais le sénat de son côté promet une
évaluation de son efficacité
et on commence bien sûr par les gilet
jaune le gouvernement devant le
parlement a tenté de répondre à la crise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est donc une semaine où tout a basculé
emmanuel macron et le gouvernement
jusqu'ici inflexible ont fini par céder
c'est le premier ministre un premier
ministre fragilisé qui a dû annoncer
puis justifié mardi et mercredi à
l'assemblée qu'ils reculaient sur la
hausse des taxes sur les carburants
moratoire dans un premier temps abandon
dans un deuxième temps retour sur ces
heurts qui marque très certainement un
tournant dans le quinquennat rabique à
suspendre les taxes pour apaiser la
colère des gilet jaune
edouard philippe là tout d'abord annoncé
en réunion de groupe mardi matin face
aux députés de la majorité
devant ses troupes le premier ministre
s'est aussi confié sur la crise que
traverse l'exécutif depuis trois
semaines nous vivons un moment délicat
nous devons réussir collectivement ce
que nous vivons c'est un moment central
de ce quinquennat en fin de matinée en
direct de matignon edouard philippe
commence son discours par à mea culpa
cette colère il faudrait être sourd ou
aveugle pour ne pas la voir ni
l'entendre aucune taxe ne mérite de
mettre en danger l'unité de la nation
dans la foulée le premier ministre
annonce un moratoire sur la hausse des
carburants pour les six mois à venir
ainsi que sur le prix de l'électricité
et du gaz
quelques heures plus tard lors des
questions au gouvernement la majorité
tout entière fait bloc pour justifier ce
qui s'apparente à un recul
monsieur le premier ministre vous auriez
pu réfléchir en politicien vous avez agi
en homme d'état
j'entends la colère qui s'exprime et
bien la sagesse monsieur le député
ça ne surprendra personne c'est de tenir
compte de ce questionnement et sans rien
renoncé de l'ambition qui est la nôtre
d'essayer d'atteindre l'objectif
le lendemain lors des cinq heures de
débats parlementaires le premier
ministre confirme cette suspension de
hausses de taxes
je le dis ici si nous ne trouvons pas
les bonnes solutions
alors nous n'appliquerons pas cette date
si et seulement si un accord intervient
nou lé inscriront dans le projet de loi
de finances rectificative des annonces
qui ne suffiront pas à calmer
l'opposition vous avez perdu la
considération des retraités des familles
des classes moyennes de celles et ceux
qui travaillent pour vivre
et comme si cela ne suffisait pas votre
gouvernement s'est alors attaqué
toujours avec la même arrogance aux
français qui ont le malheur de rouler en
voiture
allez dire au monarque présidentiel que
les gens raisonnables sont sur les
ronds-points et dans les rues et qu'il
n'en partiront pas avant que vous ayez
cédé pour de vrai où que vous soyez
partie cédé finalement l'exécutif finira
par le faire quelques heures plus tard
c'est de l'elysée que l'on apprendra que
le gouvernement ne suspend plus mais
abandonne cette taxe sur les carburants
sophie primas le gouvernement at il eu
raison de reculer le gouvernement a eu
raison d'écouter ce que senna lui disait
depuis des mois et des mois et en
particulier sur cette taxe qui a mis ça
veut dire le feu aux poudres parce que
c'est exactement le bon terme
nous nous disions premier ministre le
président larcher disait au président
macron nous parlementaires essayons
d'entamer le débat avec le gouvernement
pour leur dire attention il y à des
signaux faibles
il y à des signaux de moins en moins
faible de plus en plus fort dans les
territoires et vous êtes en train
d'accumuler une colère qui va ce qui va
qui va exploser
bon c'était très difficile de parler
avec le gouvernement avant cette crise
donc le gouvernement a bien fait
d'écouter le sénat et de céder sur cette
taxe carbone
vous dites le gouvernement il raison
d'écouter le sénat ça veut dire que pour
vous ce n'est pas un recul bah c'est pas
un recul c'est en tout cas l'écoutent du
peuple l écoute de ce qui a mis le feu
aux poudres alors maintenant est-ce que
ça suffira c'est un autre sujet je pense
qu on l'abordera mais il est temps qu'on
écoute ceux qui sont sur les territoires
qui sont les relais des élus locaux qui
eux mêmes sont les porte-parole de ce
peuple qui aujourd'hui dit vraiment une
difficulté à vivre dans le quotidien ça
qui dit aujourd'hui parler gilet jaune
parler vrai j'ai les jaunes alors pas
par les casseurs on va l'aborder tout de
suite en est ce que pour vous les
mesures annoncées cette semaine par
edouard philippe et par emmanuel macron
sont suffisantes pour sortir de cette
crise
mais je pense qu'elle aurait pu être
suffisante il ya trois semaines où il ya
quinze jours nous avons voté l'arrêt des
taxes sur le carbone que nous dénoncions
déjà l'année dernière dans le projet de
loi de finances 2010 est on peut
reprendre textuellement journal officiel
les mots par exemple de jean françois
husson qui est un sénateur républicain
qui travaille sur ces sujets là je crois
vraiment qu'il ya trois semaines on
aurait pu arrêter ça en écoutant
véritablement ce que disait le sénat qui
est jamais que ce que disent les
territoires c'est pas l'institution
sénat c'est ce que nous représentons en
réalité maintenant est-ce que ça suffira
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas il faut bien
remettre en perspective on a
l'impression que maintenant ça part dans
tous les sens que tout le monde agrège
sa colère sectorielle et donc je ne sais
pas si ça suffira
quelles mesures supplémentaires pourrait
prendre justement le gouvernement sur le
pouvoir d'achat par exemple promis ni
ses assemblées ouvert à la proposition
de xavier bertrand d'une prime de
pouvoir d'achat défiscalisées vous êtes
pour écouter jeu je pense qu'il va
falloir prendre des mesures transitoires
mais on ne réformera pas la france avec
du saupoudrage comme ça et puis des
zigzags entre déprime d'activité des
primes on voit bien qu'il s'agit d'un
saupoudrage ou peut-être que pour calmer
les choses il faut prendre une mesure
conjoncturelle mais structurellement il
faut s'attaquer effectivement à la
fiscalité dans son ensemble et à la
justice de cette fiscalité à dire
qu'aujourd'hui le débat c'est celui-là
suite la justice fiscale
bien sûr bien sûr c'est de celui de la
justice fiscale pour qu'il n'entame pas
l'énergie de la france hélas sa capacité
à investir à sa capacité à être
attractifs pour des entreprises sa
capacité à générer des investissements
privés dans des entreprises privées pour
créer de l'emploi et cia que l'emploi
qui diminuera l'injustice sociale donc
et en même temps il faut répondre à ceux
qui ont le smig et quelquefois en
dessous du smic je pense évidemment
aujourd'hui retraité je pense aux
agriculteurs je pense parfois aux
artisans qui aujourd'hui il n'y arrive
plus tout simplement finir l'oeuf à la
fin du mois sur le plan politique on
vient de revoir le déroulé des
événements le premier ministre a été
finalement contredit par l'elysée
quelques heures après s'être exprimé
devant l'assemblée moratoire puis
abandon de la taxe il ya une crise au
sein du couple exécutif lui-même
oh je pense qu'il ya des différences
structurelles mais vous savez on les
sentait venir parce que ce cette grande
illusion du ni droite ni gauche qui
exclut toute forme de consultation des
partis politiques républicains
c'est un peu une illusion et du coup
aujourd'hui chacun se retrouve en
porte-à-faux par rapport à ses
convictions par rapport à la vision
qu'il a de la société la façon dont il
doit mener la réforme et je trouve que
les cafouillages qu'on voit depuis le
début de la semaine c'est pas rassurant
pour le peuple vous voyez un qui dit
blanc l'autre qui dit noir l'autre qui
dit gris madame scapa qui va sur les
plateaux dire on va revoir lire s lisf
un bon tout ça donne quand même pas très
très bonne image de solidité de
l'exécutif dans son ensemble et du
couple président premier ministre
alors après l'assemblée nationale
mercredi à l'heure philippe et venait
jeudi s'exprimer devant le sénat après
l'assemblée nationale
direction le sénat edouard philippe doit
convaincre le reste des parlementaires
il est venu défendre son plan
d'apaisement dans l'hémicycle le silence
est glacial et c'est sur un ton presque
absent que le premier ministre s'est
adressé aux sénateurs
cette colère
vous ne découvrez pas moi non plus nous
l'avons senti monter
année après année nous devons donc
ouvrir un débat qui permette de ramener
de la clarté de la transparence dans une
question dont nous savons tous qu'elle
est très passionnel en france appelle à
la transparence à la lucidité et à la
responsabilité
le premier ministre n'a pas fait de
nouvelle annonce mais dans les rangs de
l'opposition
c'est l'heure du règlement de comptes le
chef de file des républicains dénoncent
la position d'autres juges du
gouvernement le sénat avait annulé la
hausse de taxes la hausse de taxes
c'est incompréhensible que vous ayez
accordé un moratoire nous savions vous
deviez savoir que c'était une solution
trop faible trop peu et surtout trop
tardive et qu'après ce moratoire
évidemment on vous demanderait
l'annulation c'est ce qui s'est passé à
gauchy qui n'aiment constat oui vous
auriez dû écouter plus tôt c'est cela la
lucidité
monsieur le premier ministre qu'il
aurait fallu développer oui vous auriez
dû engager un débat respectueux avec les
partenaires sociaux qui sont un facteur
d'apaisement dans notre pays la volonté
du président d'un dialogue direct avec
les français s'il a pu fonctionner
lorsqu'il était populaire lui-même vous
fait maintenant sombrer quand il ya une
crise de confiance
le en même temps et le tout à la fois en
période de crise ça ne marche pas
rétablir le dialogue et l'apaisement
l'exercice n'a pris que deux heures au
sénat mais face au gilet jaune
le gouvernement risque de mettre plus de
temps voilà pour les temps forts de
cette séance au sénat a résumé par
béatrice faisant vous étiez un bien sûr
sophie primas dans l'hémicycle alors que
le premier ministre est venu jeudi
comment vous l'avez trouvé le premier
ministre il a fatigué et pas très
convaincant on a l'impression vraiment
on qu'il était là comme un exercice
obligé qu'il n'avait pas plus de choses
à dire qu'à l'assemblée nationale et à
la nuit de cet heureux puisque
on va pas changer comme ça toutes les
deux heures de politique je les trouvais
allant dans des détails invraisemblable
quand en fait il s'agit d'une crise
presque institutionnels et qu'il s'agit
d'une crise extrêmement profonde sur la
division de notre nation la division
notre pays
le fait qu'ils aient des gens qui se
monte les uns contre les autres alors
qu'il est l'heure de faire nation de
retrouver ce sens de la cohésion
nationale
je les trouvais embourbé dans un
descriptif de justification de dans un
descriptif de mesures qui avaient été
prises il a été jusqu'à nous dire qu'on
allait donner le petit déjeuner
gratuitement dans les écoles des
quartiers difficiles voyait il y avait
un décalage entre entre le moment qu'on
vivait qui devait être un moment
solennel avec une prise de position sur
une ambition et sur une vision pour la
france de réconciliation et puis toute
une série de mesures presse canonné
c'est presque difficile de l'entendre
parce que edouard philippe c'est
quelqu'un de brillant qui amont et on
peut être en désaccord avec lui mon peut
pas lui retirer ni son intelligence ni
lui ni son brio mais là je les trouvais
extrêmement là en fait
est ce que pour vous il a une
responsabilité dans ce qui se passe
actuellement est ce que edouard philippe
a été trop droit dans ses bottes durant
cette crise edouard philippe par sa
formation par sa façon de faire juppé
est un edouard philippe et est un oui
enfin bon on va pas essayer de mettre
les gens dans les boîtes je suis en
train de tout le temps d'essai de dire
de faire cohésion mais quelqu'un qui par
son mode de fonctionnement
n'écoute pas beaucoup voilà il est
déterminé qu on ne peut pas lui
reprocher mais il n'écoute pas il
n'écoute rien il fait semblant d'écouter
les terres qu'ils consultent vous parler
mais en fait ils n'écoutent pas et c'est
ce qui est en train de se passer
aujourd'hui le résultat c'est ce qui est
en train de se passer aujourd'hui c'est
qu'à force du n'écouter personne
eh bien on s'enferme et dans sa tour
d'argent en fait semblant de faire des
déplacements à droite à gauche mais on
n'écoute pas en réalité tous les signaux
faibles qui vous sont adressés et qui
qui tempère une politique et qui permet
je dis tout le temps la réforme c'est
c'est valérie pécresse qui disait celle
qui a affronté
la réforme des universités sous nicolas
sarkozy elle disait souvent une forêt
forme c'est tiré un élastique on tire on
tire
il faut juste avoir l'intelligence de
savoir que si on tire encore un peu plus
alors l'élastique va casser aujourd'hui
l'élastique est cassé et voilà edouard
philippe c'est celui qui tire
l'élastique sans cesse mais qui
n'écoutent pas que ça commence à craquer
alors l'exécutif on l'a dit a fini par
suivre le vote du sénat
l'abandon de la taxe comment on finance
finalement ce manque à gagner le sénat
avait voté je crois une une hausse de la
contribution des mutuelles l'exécutive
dit que finalement c'est de remplacer
une taxe par une autre que de faire ça
oui alors je vais écarté tout de suite
cette polémique sur les mutuelles il
faut savoir que les mutuelles
c'est très particulier parce que les
mutuelles ont des frais d'édition qui
sont extrêmement élevées elles font je
crois 7 milliards de publicités par an
pour que les gens adhèrent à leur
mutuelle donc on leur a demandé un
effort d'1 milliard
je pense que le sujet n'est pas le sujet
des mutuelles
je pense qu'elles peuvent contribuer
aussi à l'effort de redressement public
et c'est ce que les sénat a demandé sans
augmenter le prix des mutuelles
le sénat a proposé différentes
dispositions dont certaines sont en
train d'être votée en ce moment dans le
cadre de l'examen du projet de loi de
finances d'ailleurs je dois dire assez
surréaliste un de continuer à examiner
le projet de loi de finances en même
temps qu'il se passe tout ça c'est
parfois un peu acrobatique et dans ces
mesures nous avons par exemple repris
après les révélations du monde sur la
fraude fiscale aux dividendes des
dispositions extrêmement précise et
extrêmement rapide qui permettrait selon
bercy de récupérer par exemple un
milliard et demi donc voilà une belle
source d'économies et de recettes qui
permettent de financer cet arrêt de la
taxe carbone alors des mesures annoncées
qui coûte 4 milliards c'est le chiffre
de plein fouet donné cette semaine
est-ce que face à la crise actuelle vous
dites il faut laisser filer les déficits
non non non bien sûr que non il ne faut
pas laisser filer les déficits
il y à une erreur originelle dans le
dans ce budget mais qui est l'erreur là
aussi de la non écoute moi c'était une
promesse présidentielle qui lui a
probablement permis de passer le premier
tour
qui est cette histoire de taxe
d'habitation cette taxe d'habitation ça
va coûter 3 milliards et demi cette
année on est on les voyait dans les
pures de cela et on ne sait pas comment
le compenser auprès des collectivités
territoriales c'est donc le budget de
l'état qui va compenser ça auprès des
collectivités territoriales
c'est une erreur majeure parce que
qu'est ce que nous disent les gilet
jaune aujourd'hui ils nous disent on
veut pas payer trop d'impôts
nous on veut bien payer de l'impôt
risque on veut du service public et on
veut comprendre on veut de la
transparence sur la fiscalité
or quel est le lieu vraiment où on peut
s'adresser à sont élus directement qui
est le maire pour lui dire je vous ai
payé 1000 euros d'impôts dans l'année où
vont mes 1000 euros et le maire est en
capacité de dire voilà mes choix voilà
mon financement etc
c'est véritablement auprès des
collectivités territoriales donc ça
c'est une erreur originelle pardon
pardon et ça coûtera sur le quinquennat
en année pleine
26 milliards qui va falloir trouver et
donc ça c'est vraiment une très très
mauvaise idée qui a été prise par le
gouvernement
électoraliste on n'aime pas qui n'est
pas responsable
alors on va avancer parce que la crise
politique n'est pas terminée pour le
gouvernement l'opposition cherche à
maintenir la pression une motion de
censure de gauche doit être déposé lundi
à l'assemblée pour être examinée elle
dans le cours de la semaine prochaine
elle est soutenue par les socialistes
les communistes et la france insoumise
écouter ça sert à montrer qu'il y à
d'autres voies possibles et c'est ce que
nous allons porter parce que si la
colère ne trouve pas dans les
institutions de la république
un relais et bien vous n'aurez que la
rue est donc si vous voulez que le
désordre c'est ce qu'il y ait la
possibilité d'avoir un débouché qui sont
un débouché d'ordre politique et non pas
un débouché qu'ils soient violents est
bien la seule façon de le prendre en
charge ces deux fins autres que les élus
de la république entende et fassent
entendre aussi une autre voie
dieu auquel on va s'adresser notamment
aux députés de la république en marche
également eu enfin tournée quelle quelle
violence et quel mépris du parlement
dans cette crise
moi si j'étais parlementaire de la
république en marche me sentir aimée
mais profondément
mais au delà des frondeurs je pense
qu'il ya des gens raisonnables au sein
de ce groupe politique qui voit qu'ils
comprennent ce qui se passe dans un pays
qui comprennent les munitions qui a dans
le pays et l'impératif à sortir par le
haut à sortir démocratiquement et
institutionnellement de l'ornière sophie
primas vos collègues députés les
républicains à l'assemblée doivent-ils
voter cette motion de censure
je ne sais pas je crois très honnêtement
je ne sais pas parce que on est dans une
crise grave qui peut aboutir sur une
crise institutionnelle donc redire
l'importance des différents de la
présence des différents partis
politiques me semble être une bonne idée
nous devons être des vecteurs
d'opposition républicaine est le
meilleur endroit pour avoir une
opposition républicaine c'est dans les
assemblées qu'elle se soit l'assemblée
nationale ou au sénat
donc si cette motion censure peut une
fois de plus dire au gouvernement
considérait vos opposition considérer ce
qu'elle représente dans l'expression de
la voix des populations qui les ont élus
c'est une bonne chose
après je pense qu'il ya un cafouillis
aujourd'hui institutionnel on voit bien
on l'a dit tout à l'heure et des
errances dans l'exécutif rajouter de la
confusion sur la confusion c'est aussi
un petit peu délicat alors emmanuel
macron a fait de sa capacité
réformatrice la ligne de son quinquennat
mais pourra-t-il encore mener à bien ses
réformes après cette crise est la
question que nous avons posée aux
français dans un sondage public sénat
opinionway regardait les résultats
concernant ces différentes réformes que
ce soit la loi bioéthique la réforme de
la fonction publique ou encore la
réforme des retraites est bien une
majorité des français jusque nom
emmanuel macron n'est plus à même de
mener ces réformes
est-ce que c'est aussi votre avis sophie
primas
la france a besoin de réformes et toute
la présidentielle s'est joué autour de
quelles réformes et de quelle manière on
allait mener ses réformes et la france a
besoin de réformes on a besoin de
vraiment structurellement et c'est
d'ailleurs là aussi je pense la faute de
départ d'emmanuel de macron c'est le
premier budget qui a été voté marquer le
fait qu'on aurait pas de réformes
structurelles qu'on aurait des
ajustements à droite à gauche mais pas
de réformes structurelles mais ce qui
l'est encore en capacité de les mener
ses réformes
ça va être difficile ça va être
difficile ou alors il faut qu'il les
mène encore une fois c'est ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure vraiment en
essayant de créer une union nationale
une vraie union nationale c'est-à-dire
là où il laisse la place à ses opposants
politiques républicains alors je
comprends que ça le gêne parce que tout
le jeu des manuels mâcon a été de se
dire je suis ni de droite ni gauche
georges et je suis et la droite et la
gauche et j'emmène tout le monde
et du coup je me laisse face aux
extrémistes de gauche ou de droite on
voit bien qu'on ne peut pas faire ça si
on ne laisse pas une voix un avis une
voie de sortie aux partis politiques
républicains
donc si il arrive à faire ça après c'est
cette crise peut-être arrivera-t-il à
faire des réformes qui pourront être
expliquée mais sinon ça me paraît
compliqué s'ils continuent à s'enfermer
dans son univers ça me paraît compliqué
alors on début de semaine un autre fait
marquant de cette semaine la commission
des lois des les commissions des lois
des deux assemblées ont auditionné le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner son secrétaire d'état laurent
nunès pour comprendre comment de telles
violences ont pu avoir lieu le 1er
décembre dernier devant le sénat et
devant l'assemblée christophe castaner à
assumer ses responsabilités mais a dit
qu'on ne pouvait pas parler d'échec des
forces de l'ordre est ce que pour vous
néanmoins christophe castaner a failli
christophe castaner est là depuis pas
très très longtemps
bon donc on va lui laisser le bénéfice
du doute et bénéfices de l'adaptation de
ce qui pourrait se passer dans les
semaines prochaines
moi je crois que les forces de l'ordre
les hommes et les femmes qui sont les
forces de l'ordre et qui ont servi de
rempart n'ont pas failli parce qu'elles
ont fait ce qu'on leur a demandé le
gouvernement avait trois objectifs et
les forces de l'ordre avait trois
objectifs premiers objectifs on l'a très
bien vu dans les auditions c'était
protéger les lieux institutionnels
protéger l elysée protéger l'assemblée
nationale protège un certain nombre de
lieux emblématiques de la république
le deuxième c'était d'essayer de gérer
l'expression du dégel et jaune sur les
champs-elysées en toute sécurité voilà
et le troisième c'est être disséminé des
fortes dans les rues adjacentes
bon on voit bien que ce système là
finalement bon a été suivie mais il
n'est plus du tout adaptée à un escadron
de frelons com comment pour l image et
qui se dispersent partout pour faire de
l'ultra violence donc là où ça a failli
c'est que on est plus en phase avec
cette nouvelles violences allez on
avance dans l'émission sophie primas
pour parler d'un autre sujet qui a fait
débat cette semaine la réforme de
l'impôt sur la fortune
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les gilet jaune et une partie de
l'opposition réclame son rétablissement
le sénat en avait débattu mais l'avait
rejetée emmanuel macron a clos le débat
mercredi soir pas question de rétablir
lisf a dit le chef de l'état mais le
sénat a promis une évaluation de cette
mesure dont l'efficacité fait débat
flora sauvage c'est une fin de non
recevoir
pas question de répondre à l'une des
revendications des gilet jaune qui
veulent le retour de l'impôt sur la
fortune
promesse de campagne d'emmanuel macro
lisf avait été supprimée en janvier 2018
est remplacé par l'impôt sur la fortune
immobilière
l'explication de texte avec le ministre
des comptes publics
on va pas changer la politique
économique de notre pays changer sa
politique fiscale toutes les semaines
qu'il y ait dans un an dans deux ans que
le parlement fasse une évaluation qu'on
modifie des choses lorsqu'on aura
constaté quelque chose fonctionne au
fonctionnel c'est normal c'est de la
démocratie mais il n'y aura pas de
retour de laisser d'autres pays
face à la contestation edouard philippe
a annoncé la mise en place d'un comité
d'évaluation de la politique fiscale
le sénat quant à lui va créer un groupe
de travail sur la fiscalité du
patrimoine indépendants du pouvoir
exécutif fusion pour le président
socialiste de la commission des finances
qui s'appuie sur des chiffres fournis
par bercy les effets de la réforme de
l'isf semble limité on a quand même une
vision d'une réforme a peu d'effet 50000
emplois 05 que 1.2 pipe sur 20 ans est
même pas exceptionnellement lourd en
2010 est moins de 1% des ménages ont été
assujettis à l isf et cet impôt a
rapporté 5 milliards d'euros à l'état
pour la gauche la suppression de l' isf
est un cadeau fait aux plus riches de
donner pour le gouvernement elle est
nécessaire pour encourager les
contribuables les plus aisés à investir
en france sophie primas rétablir les ss
est une des demandes de nombreux gilet
jaune vous êtes pour ou contre
vous savez que les républicains ont
toujours été plutôt pour une suppression
de l' isf moi je crois qu'il faut
laisser à cet impôt à cette suppression
d'impôt le temps d'être évalués donc
c'est ce que nous avons demandé au sénat
on peut pas dire six mois après ça
marche ça marche pas ce que l'on veut
c'est que les personnes qui sont les
plus aisés
et qui ont des grandes fortunes ce qu'on
voit on est sur un pour cent qui
rapporte 5 milliards envoyés la
concentration de l'impôt que ces
personnes là reviennent en france qu'on
puisse les imposer d'ailleurs au passage
et que ça parte pas à droite à gauche
et puisqu'elle met l'argent dans
l'économie donc c'est ça qu'il faut
évaluer si ça marche il faut le garder
mais il faut accompagner cette réforme
de l'isf par d'autres réformes plus
structurelles qui parle aux personnes
les plus modestes sinon ça ne peut pas
fonctionner et c'est le totem de
l'injustice sociale
donc vous dites gilet jaune qui pour
certains contestent cette mesure que
c'est une mesure ce remplacement lier
cet impôt sur la fortune immobilière
c'est une bonne mesure économiquement je
ne sais pas il faut il faut l'évaluer
voilà il faut l'évaluer moi je pense que
c'est une bonne mesure parce que ça
permet aux personnes les plus riches de
rester sur le territoire donc de les
imposer donc de faire entrer des
recettes et ça permet d'imaginer
qu'elles vont mettre leur argent dans
l'économie c'est peut-être là d'ailleurs
qu'il faut peut-être mieux fléché ses
économies sur les sf vers le productif
mais peut-être que c'est pas vrai il
faut l'évaluer il faut avoir les
chiffres fiables
donc c'est ce que nous allons faire au
sénat et nous suivrons bien sûr tout ça
dans cette émission merci beaucoup merci
sophie primas ce d'avoir été avec nous
cette semaine merci thibault et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une
nouvelle semaine d'actualité
parlementaire
[Musique]